mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
in square abcd
connect the corner a to the opposite
side dc
dividing it into lengths of one and two
repeat this procedure for the other
three corners of the square
the result will be four lines that bound
a square shown in blue
the question is what is the area of the
square in blue
divided by the area of the square abcd
in other words what fraction of the
square abcd is shaded in blue
you can also solve the general problem
where we replace 2 with the variable x
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
one way to solve this problem is by
considering the area of the
parallelogram shown in green
we'll calculate its area in two
different ways
one way to calculate the area is by
taking the base of x and the height of x
plus one
the area is then the product of the base
and the height which is equal to x
multiplied by the quantity x plus one
but there's another way that we can
calculate the area of the parallelogram
we'll take the height to be the length s
of this square and we'll take the base
to be the hypotenuse of this right
triangle
we can calculate the length of this
hypotenuse using the gogu theorem it'll
be equal to the square root of 1 plus
the quantity x plus 1 squared we then
take the product of the base and the
height to get another formula for the
area of the parallelogram
we thus have two different ways to
express the area of the parallelogram so
we set those equal to each other
we'll then solve this equation for s
we want the area of this square which
will be equal to s squared
we then want to divide it by the area of
the entire square abcd
this is equal to the quantity x plus one
squared
we thus take the ratio
we'll then cancel out the x plus one
squared terms and that'll leave us with
the fraction of the square that's shaded
in blue
we can then solve for particular values
for example if x is equal to two we can
easily calculate that the fraction
that's shaded in blue will be equal to
two over five and that's the answer
it's a very neat geometry problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you